la neige est arrivée ce week end et
lundi après-midi les flocons sont encore
tombés sur le sol saint quentinois le
département des yvelines est placé en
vigilance orange jusqu'à 22 heures
l'ensemble des routes primaires et
secondaires ont été traités sur la
communauté d'agglomération les saleuses
ont cumulé les sorties au total sept
pour ce week-end
120 tonnes de sel ont été déversées sur
les grands axes ainsi que des petites
routes
si les transports scolaires avait été
interrompue aujourd'hui ils reprendront
demain le réseau ce qui vu celui a
déclenché son plan neige impliquant le
déplacement de certains terminus exemple
avec la ligne 463 qui n'a pas pu accéder
au quartier de la clé saint-pierre à
elancourt outre les retards tous les bus
articulés ont été rentrés au dépôt
entraînant la suppression de quelques
courses
la neige devrait tomber jusqu'à 22h
formant une couche de 2 à 5 cm
d'épaisseur
on va tourner autour de zéro degré et en
fin de nuit on pourra descendre à moins
à moins 3 ce qui peut entraîner quelques
problèmes de glace au sol
sur le réseau secondaire demain épisode
pluvio neigeux est attendu en fin de
matinée avant un retour dans l'après
midi
mais jeudi retour du froid avec des
températures négatives